I'll turn my camera I keep my fingers hi
guys so it's the last talked before
lunch I know how you're feeling you're
hungry me too but we'll go through it
together we'll survive okay so let's
start so my talk is called reactive
programming made simple and it's mostly
about user interfaces of the client site
in the browser but basically what i'm
going to show you you can apply it in
regular programming as well so i'm from
meter and meter is a company that
develops an open source framework and
the main purpose of meter is to make it
really easy to build modern web
applications and it should be easy to
everyone not only beginners advanced
users like intermediate programmers and
they it's all in JavaScript so what is
modern web applications we have an
example here that comes with meter and
it's called to do that as you know every
JavaScript framework should have a to do
that so this is one example built with
meter so we have lists it has data i can
add stuff go to is evil right i can add
it you can see the number here increases
i can check it off blah blah blah delete
awesome so actually all the data here is
synchronized to like a server in north
america in the united states so even
though it's taking half a second to
connect to that server you still don't
see any latency all the actions are
immediate because we simulate all the
actions of the client-side that's one of
the features of meteor and because it's
all persistent i can open another
browser window and perform some changes
here and you will see them appear to on
the left side as well and you can see
that on the right side is much faster
because it's happening in simulation
before the classic sure we'll go to the
server so this is one of the examples of
meteor applications
so modern web applications it's a lot of
things in our view at meteor we try to
encourage people to use a lot of modern
patterns such as a morphic JavaScript
something spike talked about instant
responses client-side simulations the
active you I the all times visualization
blah blah blah a lot of things so that a
lot of things in videos that we build
its kind of amazing but I don't have
time to talk about all of that today so
I'm going to focus on one feature that I
think will be useful to you and if you
want to learn more about meter I thought
maybe I shouldn't give you another
introduction to it because it's already
been done before by my coworker Emily
stark on Jess called Asia 2013 in manual
so you can go there and see the
introductions there I hope you'll like
it but today um I want to give you some
things that you can use outside of meter
because I know you all guys have jobs
probably you cannot switch to meet you
in one moment I'm not even trying to
convince you it's okay so let's see what
meteor is media is any big system
consists of a lot of different packages
components and I know somebody could
tell you hey meter is another model
istics things you cannot separate things
out that's not true this is the basic
stack legs are several major components
something like getting real-time data
updates from database or like giving
them to the client or simulations as a
client side and this one components that
I want to talk about today is called
checker this is a small UI libraries
that we use to get to manage the
dependency floor like if you imagine you
have a lot of components they all depend
on each other they need to synchronize
their state somehow and you can use this
slider in the applications so here's an
example of like applications that you
all know bubbly it's Twitter and see as
you know when you have fairly complex
you I you get more and more components
you try to split it out on smaller and
smaller parts so it's easier to manage
so you can imagine it looks something
like this I
I just made made it up but you might
think that it's good we separate our
concerns we isolated each component but
in the allergy component still depend on
each other so if this a new tweet it
appears in the main feed it can appear
the number increasing somewhere else if
there's a picture it will appear in the
pictures component so they really can
depend on each other so here's another
example it's a YouTube dashboard and
this is something a lot of people don't
see this is a dashboard for people who
are plaut videos so you can see my most
popular video is about my high school
graduation silico but this is a complex
page there's a lot of things going on so
you have type-ahead search you have some
charting library you have a calendar
view where you can select something and
let's say you want to implement
something I exist and you work in a
smaller company may be here in Singapore
maybe somewhere else you probably don't
have two hundred engineers to build it
overnight so what do you do if you're
lazy like me you will go on the internet
and find a lot of libraries that can
help you I don't want to build my
calendar of you again I don't have two
miles maybe somebody olej build it for
me right so that's exactly what you're
going to do probably you will use
something like a package as for
type-ahead search you will render your
views with that component for calendar
you will use full calendar jquery plugin
for SVG gasps you'll use some library
like this vijay's this is a data table
that needs sorting and everything I
don't know if if somebody already did it
for me efficiently I'll just use their
code so here you have several components
and they built with entirely different
frameworks sorry libraries and they
built with entirely different teams this
code doesn't have any idea how to work
with each other and yeah like you can
use something else for this line so my
point is you have all the things you
need to glue together how do you do that
and just to give you another example
here's google calendar in case you think
oh you just synchronize your data model
for every component it's not true
sometimes you
and on the state of the component so
here on the left side you have this box
where you can select some weak arbitrary
range of days in your calendar and that
would be reflected on the right side so
it's not even like data that comes for
user it's something that is stored as a
state of the component so let's say you
start developing that but you know this
thing depends on that saying blind
showed up down only if this constraints
are satisfied you will do some graph
dependency graph like this by the way
it's not real graph I just made it up
but the point is it might be simple in
the beginning but more features you have
in your applications more different
directions the activity will go to or
dependencies will go to it will be
harder to manage and maybe you don't
need to is our job really managing
dependencies probably not so you may end
up with something like this it's all
complicated goes back and forth you
manage events here you pushes they're
like what's going on so that's why we
built a small library called tracker
it's under two kilobytes when gzipped
and minified is really small and lean
and the point is to make any code
deactive you just wrap whatever code you
have into one function call it just
instantly becomes the active at what I
mean is every time some dependency
changes of that function or like that
block it will just sound again so the
purpose is just to you know glue things
together and here's an example a code
example you just put your stuff into
this checker-outer on and alternate
means it will run again at the game
again every time something changes so
here's another example let's say I have
a valuable called city it's San
Francisco that's wearing form and we
paint both casting from this city so so
like first time it will run it will
paint I'm broadcasting from San
Francisco but next time the city will
change it will immediately run again and
it will paint I'm broadcasting from
Singapore and it will do it itself you
just change your variables however you
want here's another example just to make
the
that tracker is not to dump for you
let's say we have two variables and
since this outer on I check the secret
variable and if this qu i will say I'm
not going to tell you what the city is
if there's not choose and I i can tell
you okay in the city is this so Cherica
looks at this code it understands that
secret is true in the beginning so only
the first block will execute so the
second block of the if statement is
essentially that block it will not run
ever until secret will change so it
doesn't matter if you change city like
hundred times it will not run again
because check and assess oh it didn't
change anyway so it will print only once
and then you change the ticket and it
will do all the right things so it's
kind intelligent in this case so
dependency tracking is not a new thing
and if you look at the modern UI
frameworks they're mostly like they're
often implemented in the context of data
bindings so you have your data model I
want to keep it in sync with this part
of the page okay i have my data binding
and usually it's really hard to use this
mechanism of dependency traction outside
of this framework with other components
or like code not related to you I at all
so for example this is angular example
and i'm not a big expert in angular so
if you hate me for that please sorry i
have my computer per particle say hello
it just matches my first name last name
and you'll notice here that all the
valuables are attached to this dollar
sign scope so what is dollar signs cope
it's special things that angular has and
it's different from the JavaScript's
curbs that you have in each function and
you need to remember to do that and
there's something magical about it
because what anglo does under the hood
it pulls these valuables on the scope
and see if anything changed and this
something they call judge checking so
this is good but it's mostly done in the
context of data bindings and it's not
really useful outside of angular
so in amber it's kinda simpler you still
use the same JavaScript code but what I
don't like about it you need to specify
manually what are you dependencies of
your function like already use first
name and last name why do I need to tell
amber what are the exact properties I
depend on why can't you figure it out
yourself so this is samson check out
that's better and it's really small you
can use it with different things here's
an example of examples let's say you
have a glove that you'll end up and use
this V and every time something changes
you need to e bind your data or you have
a full calendar and every time you want
to display a different range you need to
set this date to your calendar or you
have child jazz or like video player
every time different API a different
thing like if you have n components and
you need to connect them between each
other you'll do l squared extra coding
for each of those connections and it
goes both ways it's not only inside the
component it's also outside of it so
whenever the events triggered like oh I
clicked on say saying or I went to this
date or I I jumped to this location for
the playback oh I pose so I started all
of those are like extra things you need
to code up connect together with event
handlers which checker is much easier
you just connect everything to check at
once and that's it and you can use the
same code because most times the code is
pretty much a it important so you can
just line it again at the game so let's
go back to the YouTube example so I have
all these components so at this point
what I'll do I'll just connect each of
them to checker and checker will make
sure that all the reactive valuables are
checking the right advance to endow
again so here's my demo there's a very
simple page you can it's a forecast
weather app it's not really an app it's
more like a page so here I say it's
beautiful day today's Thursday or Friday
and here's the forecast for the whole
week and here's a small child so for the
purpose of this demo I'm going to
implement it with mental Dom
manipulations we access because why not
it's a
library and charting library so it can
really happen in your application as
well you can have one part that this
kind a legacy code developed by some guy
who left a long time ago also you have
another part built with the ad because
it's a new hotness and there's a new
developer who decided just to build
everything can react and this is
charging Clyde way because well who
knows how to build charts I don't so
yeah and here's the code I don't know
why my syntax highlighting the swirl but
I hope it's still easy to it for Dom
manipulations we just got an element
assign in the text and we use current
date and temperatures forecast for your
address you just render this component
it's very simple you just passing you
temperatures about temperatures data and
for the charging light but it's a bit
more complicated because it's charging
five but he needs extra babysitting what
changed why do I need to like tell you
specifically I need to go through all
your data data structures and like set
it manually unfortunately that's how
this library works the ones that I
picked so sometimes you need to update
it this way so let's go to the live
coding demo way scary ok so here's the
basic page and I need the console ready
to go ok sorry show website developer ok
so I don't have any code here you just
have basic HTML markup so as you can see
nothing happens and you can see is the
date even correct it's not even correct
it says it's mundane it's clearly not so
let's do let's do some Dom manipulation
I know it's awful but well bear with me
so i will get element by ID in this case
my ID is day for the purpose of this
demo and i will set you know texture
current date
and what's a sports okay it displays
this because I do it in manual Dom
manipulations so I'll make it a bit
nicer and I'll just start getting two
separate variable and i'll choose the
stream from the days of the week array
just so it's easier to see so i'll get
today and it go safe I day cool it's
fine thing right okay but let's change
the current date let's go to the future
let's set it to something in the future
in 2014 november and 21st nothing
happens why because it's code is not
reactive how do i make it active well
that's easy I'll just wrap this code
into a function declaration and I'll
call check it out loud which is just
like the only API is that we have here
love this again every time it changes so
i will refresh and i'll set it to the
future and it changes to monday yay
works so i have also a prebuilt
functions that is random I that is on
demising the current date and let me
call that so set interval randomly
change date and execute it very often so
yeah it's changing all the time cool so
I'll do the same with the current
temperature so this pan is forecast and
I'll just get this temperature for my
active arrays that I declared online 30
temperatures get the jet date
okay it's a 31 so yeah it works so now
let me do the same for other things and
I don't want to code in front of you
it's kind of embarrassing because they
can make a lot of mistakes let me just
copy paste something from my example
that I already built so I'll do the same
thing I'll instantiate tracker outrun
and inside I'll just render the
component with temperatures and because
we use the same temperatures array
basically it should be synchronized some
cincuenta where you get a safe oh do
they go to the wrong place sorry okay
here what I want to do ok here it is a
list built with react vertical you can
imagine some fancy component so now I
can call a different set interval that
will randomly change my values in my
array so let's imagine data comes from
each other and there's some service
about whether as it always changed its
mind it tells you oh actually the
temperature will be different so let's
do this I'll call randomly update
forecast and call it here we often so
yeah yay it's really called on Monday be
careful okay the last piece the last
piece is charged as example so here's
the code I talked about before and again
the same thing just wrap it in to check
it out the run and make sure your
function is idempotent and like you
correctly instantiate it first and then
you just updated data so i will refresh
it oh yeah we have a graph and it's 31
30 32 so it's all great so let's do the
same thing again let's just randomize it
it's pretty cool huh I even prepared
some music for you
I think this graph actually knows how to
dance for so yeah this was my demo so
what we did we just at every sync it to
check out that something was hard so
recap checker is a small library it's
part of meteors as how meteor does all
the fun parent reactivity magic the
thing is in meteor we kind of hide it
under the hood so like users don't
actually need to wrap everything in this
function calls so it's very intuitive
just to write your code ones without
even you know thinking about the
activity and it's really easy to use it
outside of meteor to glue things
together and they hope when you guys go
home you can look at it it's really
short you can actually read it and you
can learn something from it or maybe
even use it so you don't even need to
get into meter to use it it's useful on
its own so it smart enough to keep you
lazy and use other components and glue
things together but it's not smart
enough to do all the work for you
otherwise you won't get paid so much so
is it did we want lunch right hungry
yeah it said Thank You Slava thank you
fast snappy UI development with tracker
questions it so I mean I'm still
learning me today as um so I'm just
wondering is it possible to a science
string to a checker function and then I
can turn it so nice auto running right
is it possible Tony off sometimes and
then turn you on again yeah you can turn
them off and you can turn them on again
I didn't cover that that part but what
you can do you can do it in both ways in
two ways so you can either safe
available for this computation and then
you can stop it later we see desktop you
can do this all what you can do alto
natively actually it will be passed as a
first argument to the function so you
can stop it here inside so both options
are valid cool thanks yeah sure cool one
more I was interested in knowing how the
dependencies are being resolved for
every function to descend into autorun
do you use like you convert the function
to string and I can talk about that so
the question is how does how do we track
the pen disease that's basically what
checker does all right we check the
balance is whenever they change the
function again so the thing is if you
noticed i used reactive variables
interactive arrays everywhere so this is
kind of a catch because so one of the
part of the answer is in the future we
can use acma script five setters and
getters but right now they're not
supported in every browser I am looking
at ie but once you can do that you can
wrap all the objects and you don't even
need to use get or set of functions and
we can convert this variables for you so
what happens I'm check all the lines of
code first time and just a way a date
like the flow of the program works it
can notice what variables got cold so in
this case secret will get cold but CT
will not get cold so check out
understand that right now if nothing
changes only secret matters always it
justifiable matters the second viable
doesn't matter at all because it wasn't
even reach
like essentially right now it's dead
code and when you change those variables
it says oh like make sure you will learn
your digest loop next time and you'll
update and propagate all the changes and
I hope that answers the question big
round of applause for sabah